clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abbott toi les sensations
fortes vous allez bien moi j'aime bien
par exemple alors bon c'est pas toujours
facile de trouver un spot pour faire de
la chute libre et puis bon il faut être
entraînés et tout ça mais sans aller
jusque là il ya plein de moyens de se
faire un petit shoot d'adrénaline
facilement mais est ce que vous savez ce
qui se passe exactement dans votre corps
dans ces cas là
non et ben moi je sais et je vais vous
expliquer ça non mais ça va pas je vais
pas vous raconter ça le cul vissé sur un
fauteuil qui rend ce
jeu c'est ce qu'on va faire
pour être mieux là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour les amateurs de sensations fortes
seront pas forcément temps de suivre un
entraînement de la nasa il ya les roller
coaster la vitesse l'accélération les
changements de direction les boss la
tête en bas il y en a pour tous les
goûts après bon il ya aussi ceux qui
n'aiment pas ça il ya toujours moyen de
s'amuser toute façon
[Musique]
ouais mais pour les amateurs il ya plein
de trucs qui se passent à l'intérieur de
nous quand on est seul coup dans tous
les sens et on va voir ça tout de suite
[Musique]
le premier truc à savoir c'est que les
émotions fortes elle met un peu notre
corps en panique on a eu l'occasion d'en
parler mais en gros notre organisme il
est un peu à l'ancienne quand notre
cerveau reçoit l'information qui se
passe un truc pas habituel l'identifient
ça comme une menace en fait il est resté
bloqué à l'époque ont porté les peaux de
bêtes et il pense qu on est attaqué par
un prédateur sasa actifs différentes
zones de notre cerveau comme l'amygdale
l'hypothalamus l'hypophyse et c est ça
déclenche la production de différentes
substances chimiques dont la plus
célèbre et l'adrénaline mais c'est pas
la seule c'est tout un cocktail
d'hormones et de neurotransmetteurs qui
vont mettre notre corps dans les
conditions pour faire face à une attaque
de prédateurs à savoir combattre ou
sensuelle et dans les deux cas ce dont
on va avoir le plus besoin c'est nos
muscles pour se battre ou pour courir
très vite donc pour les rendre plus
efficaces on va leur apporter plus de
100 et plus d'oxygène en augmentant la
fréquence cardiaque et la fréquence
respiratoire c'est pour ça que quand on
est dans une attraction à sensations
fortes on a le coeur qui s'emballe et le
souffle un peu court plus ou moins selon
les gens mais ça on va y revenir ok donc
ça c'est la base et ce n'est pas
spécifique aux attractions mais il se
passe plein d'autres choses dans notre
corps quand on a la tête en bas par
exemple j'ai bien envie de savoir ce qui
se passe dans mon corps dans celui-là tu
es avec moi romain
étudiant avec moi rodin allait bien
[Musique]
la première chose à laquelle vous pensez
c'est sûrement les nausées voire un peu
plus
et vous vous dites sûrement que tout ça
c'est une histoire purement digestives
alors qu'en fait non alors bien sûr
quand on a la tête en bas ce qu'on a
mangé ça vient faire coucou à l'entrée
de l'estomac cayla tout en haut et ça
peut donner à notre corps l'impression
que c'est trop plein et qu'il faut faire
un peu de place ça participe au
processus mais en réalité pas tant que
ça en réalité c'est au niveau de
l'oreille que ça se passe oui
effectivement ça a l'air bizarre mais je
vous explique nos oreilles elles nous
servent pas uniquement à écouter de
douces mélodies
le long de notre conduit auditif là tout
au fond il ya des petits organes très
particulier dans ce qu'on appelle
l'oreille interne c'est là qu'il ya ce
qu'on appelle le système vestibulaire
qui est responsable de l' équilibre en
gros ces trois petits tuyaux en forme de
boucle qui sont placés dans des
positions qui correspondent aux trois
plans de l'espace on les appelle les
canots semi circulaires et à l'intérieur
de ces canaux il ya un liquide quand on
bouge la tête ça fait aussi bouger le
liquide à l'intérieur du canal qui
correspond à laax dans lequel elle bouge
le mouvement de ce liquide il est
détecté par des petits poils des petits
s'il en fait pour être précis et
l'information elle remonte au cerveau
pour indiquer dans quelle position se
trouve la tête et dans quel sens ça
bouge quand on est dans un manège et
qu'on fait des loopings le cerveau il
reçoit des informations contradictoires
le temps que l'info est en bas arrivent
jusqu'à lui on a déjà la tête à
l'endroit donc nouveaux messages etc et
comme en plus le liquide et les petits
cl ils sont secoués un petit peu dans
tous les sens ça fait vraiment beaucoup
d'infos à traiter en même temps et le
système bugs si vous voulez c'est ce qui
peut provoquer cette sensation de
vertige qui donne la tête qui tourne et
des nausées et ça peut même continuer un
petit peu une fois que ça s'arrête et
qu'on est descendu du manège mais il ya
aussi un autre phénomène auquel on fait
pas forcément attention et qui peut nous
faire voir un peu flou
littéralement pour le haut parce que
vous le savez peut-être pas mais on est
équipé d'un stabilisateur d'image
intégré et devinez quoi il est contrôlé
par l'oreille interne avec c'est
incroyable tous contre avec nous ok je
vous raconte quand on a la tête qui
bouge les signaux qui sont émis par nos
canaux semi circulaire la stimule aussi
les muscles de nos yeux oui on a des
muscles aux yeux par exemple quand notre
tête bouge vers la droite le liquide des
canaux ils bougent aussi comme on l'a
dit est le signal qu'ils envoyaient il
va déclencher un réflexe qui s'appelle
le réflexe vestibule au oculaire
vestibule haut comme système
vestibulaire le truc de l'équilibré de
notre oreille interne et oculaires comme
les yeux quand la tête bouge vers la
droite
les neurones vestibulaire ils vont
déclencher la contraction de certains
muscles qui font bouger nos yeux et le
relâchement d'autres de ses muscles pour
les forcer à aller dans la direction
opposée c'est à dire vers la gauche le
but de ce réflexe c'est que quand notre
tête bouge on puisse garder une vision à
peu près fixes et stable de ce qui se
passe en face de nous à peu près
et par ailleurs les informations qui
sont transmises par notre système des
stimulants elle déclenche aussi d'autres
types de réflexes qui sont chargés de
maintenir notre tête et notre corps à
peu près droit quand il ya des
changements de position trop brutaux
parce que notre corps pense qu'on est en
train de tomber ou de perdre l'équilibré
et il veut rétablir la situation alors
c'est vrai que quand on est assis dans
une attraction ça sert moins forcément
mais c'est quand même ce qui explique
que parfois on marche pas droit en
descendant d'un manège parce que même
quand on est descendu le système
vestibulaire et continuent à envoyer des
signaux un petit peu contradictoire au
cerveau qui a du mal à s'y retrouver et
lui du coup il envoie lui même des
messages aux muscles pour dire adressé à
redresser on n'est pas droit alors qu'en
fait si on les droits enfin non en fait
du coup on marche pas droit parce qu'on
essaye de se remettre droit alors qu'à
la base on était déjà droit du coup mais
plus droit bref pour en revenir aux yeux
dans les manèges où on tourne très vite
sur le même pendant longtemps même une
fois que ça s'arrête nos yeux il
continue à bouger un petit peu tellier
aux mêmes réflexes de stabilisation
d'image dont on vient de parler et vous
avez vu les yeux il reste pas coincé
dans un coin et ils font pas le tour à
l'intérieur de leurs beats non plus il
ya une espèce de réflexe qui fait que
quand les yeux arrivent dans le coin ils
retournent à leur point de départ mais
comme l'oreille interne envoie le
message que non en fait ça continue il
retourne directe peer depuis hier
tourner puis reviennent ça donne ce
mouvement répétitif et saccadé des yeux
un petit peu comme quand vous regardez
un paysage par la fenêtre d'un train ce
mouvement ça s'appelle un y stagnent us
alors je sais on dirait le nom d'un
groupe de black metal mais c'est juste
le nom scientifique est en l'occurrence
ça s'appelle même un is time us poste
rotatoire après la la rotation alors
tranquille il n'y avait rien de méchant
dans tout ce que je viens de vous
raconter et puis surtout ça se calme
quand on se pose est que le cerveau
reçoit plus qu'une seule information
c'est bon ça bouge plus on a la tête
droite alors deux petits conseils quand
même si vous aimez les roller coaster
l'alcool ça modifie à la fois la texture
du liquide dans les canaux qui réagit
plus tout à fait comme d'habitude du
coup et aussi la transmission des
informations sur la position du corps
dans l'espace qui doit remonter jusqu'au
cerveau
c'est pour ça que quand on a trop bu bas
on marche pas droit et on a tendance à
perdre et ils vont donc si vous avez
l'intention de boire un coup fait ça
plus tôt après et bien sûr ce que vous
avez dans l'estomac ça compte un petit
peu quand même donc vous pouvez manger
avant mais vous gaver pas c'est pas la
peine de tenter le diable au pire ça
nous permettra de limiter la casse il ya
un problème un autre truc que vous
disiez peut-être aussi c'est que avoir
la tête en bas ça fait monter le sang au
cerveau et que c'est ça qui donne des
sensations
alors qu'en fait à moins de rester très
longtemps la tête en bas non pas
vraiment ceci dit vous aviez quand même
un petit peu raison parce que les roller
coaster ça joue aussi sur la circulation
du sang mais c'est plutôt une histoire
d'accélération vous savez les fameux g
dont on entend parler dans l'aviation ou
dans le domaine spatial en gros un gc
l'accélération qui correspond à la
pesanteur terrestre
c'est à dire 9 8 mètres par seconde par
seconde oui ça fait deux fois par
seconde moi aussi je trouve ça un peu
compliqué pour dire les choses autrement
disons que 1 g ce serait une voiture qui
augmente sa vitesse de 35 km heure
chaque seconde donc au bout d'une
seconde elle va à 35 kilomètres heure ou
deux secondes à 70 km/heure et ainsi de
suite mais bon on n'est pas des bagnoles
alors pour en revenir aux êtres humains
voilà à quoi ça ressemble un visage du
de l'extérieur quand il est soumis à 9 g
pendant plusieurs longues secondes c'est
spécial 1 en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que ça déforme les tissus mous du visage
mais dites vous que à l'intérieur se
passe des trucs aussi
alors attention à on parle d'une
exposition prolongée à 9 g c'est énorme
alors que nous avec romain là on a été
exposé à un peu moins de 4 g sur un
temps très court dans ces cas là je sais
pas si vous voyez on sent comme écrasés
dans notre fauteuil ce qui se passe en
fait c'est que à 4 g pour schématiser
notre corps qui pèse 4 fois son poids
habituel
d'où cette sensation est à l'intérieur
le sang ne circule pas non plus comme
d'habitude il est envoyé vers le bas du
corps ça veut dire que pour le coup on a
moins de sens qui monte à la tête donc
moins de sens qui monte au cerveau et
c'est ce qui peut donner en plus de
touristes d'une impression de tête qui
tourne là encore pour les gens qui sont
en bonne santé ce n'est pas dangereux
mais c'est pour ça que les attractions à
sensations elles sont déconseillés pour
les gens qui ont des problèmes
cardiovasculaires évident en fait on
estime que si on est exposé à 4 g4g
ennemis de manière un peu prolongé on
peut commencer à avoir un voile gris
voire un voile noir qui passe devant les
yeux c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas loin
de perdre connaissance la perte de
connaissance elles arrivent en général
vers 5 g pour les gens qui sont pas
entraînés d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
les pilotes ont commencé à porter les
combinaisons anti g en gros c'est des
vêtements qui comprime les jambes pour
éviter que tout le sens des cendres
dedans et pour qu'il en reste un peu
gros cerveau et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'ils suivent des entraînements qui
leur permet de supporter jusqu'à 9 g a
pas tous est frit kentucky
ça c'est pour les jets positif mais il
ya aussi des jets négatif c'est ce qui
nous donne un peu l'impression qu'on
décolle de sièges est d'ailleurs parfois
c'est pas juste une impression dans ces
cas là les mouvements du manège il faut
qu'on passe de vers le haut et vers le
bas très rapidement à cet instant précis
on passe sous les 1 g et c'est comme si
le poids de notre corps était plus bas
que d'habitude
c'est ce qui donne cette impression
d'être en suspension dans l'air de volée
mais bon ça dure très peu de temps et
heureusement d'ailleurs parce que
bizarrement pour les pilotes c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de s'entraîner à
supporter les jets négatif que léger
positif parce que là pour le coup quand
ils sont exposés longtemps à des jets
négatif leur sang il est envoyé vers le
cerveau et ça donne des maux de tête et
des troubles de la vision et notamment
un qui s'appelle le voile rouge mais bon
là je m'égare ça concerne pas les
attractions on en reparlera peut-être un
de ces jours ci je fais de la voltige
aérienne par exemple
pareil je vous parle pas du zéro g comme
dans les avions qui recrée les
conditions de la pesanteur mais
peut-être un jour aussi pourquoi pas
voilà c'est principalement ce qui se
passe dans notre corps quand on est dans
ce genre de la traction à sensations
fortes mais regardez attentivement ces
images
[Applaudissements]
comme vous pouvez le constater on ne
réagit pas du tout de la même manière le
fait que certaines personnes ne
supportent et aiment les sensations
fortes et d'autres moins voire pas du
tout c'est lié à la fois à des facteurs
physiques et psychologiques en fonction
de sa morphologie est son état physique
de base déjà tout le monde ressent pas
les mêmes effets on n'a pas toutes et
tous exactement la même oreille interne
les mêmes connexions nerveuses la même
fonction cardiaque et c'est l'habitude
ça joue aussi la preuve les pilotes ils
ont des entraînements spécifiques pour
s'habituer aux conditions extrêmes et
puis tout le monde n'a pas la même
capacité à supporter les mêmes choses en
admettant que ce soit mesurable si deux
personnes ressentent exactement les
mêmes effets il y en a une qui peut très
bien le supporter voir les apprécier et
l'autre qui peut être complètement au
bout de sa vie ça s'explique par plein
de choses et notamment par le fait que
tout le monde n'aime pas ça et il ya
plusieurs raisons à ça aux etats unis un
professeur en psychologie qui s'appelle
marvin zhu karman qui s'est intéressé à
la question dès les années 60 pour lui
la recherche de sensations fortes c'est
un vrai traits de personnalité et il a
passé sa carrière à l'étudier et à
essayer de comprendre comment ça
fonctionne notamment au niveau du neuro
biologiques en 2018 en allemagne le
docteur marie othily fraenkel a étudié
deux groupes de personnes un groupe de
personnes qui aiment les sensations
fortes et un groupe de personnes qui
n'aiment pas ça elle les a mis dans des
situations extrêmes et voilà ce qu'elle
a pu déterminer après leur avoir fait
des examens le groupe des personnes qui
recherchait habituellement les
sensations fortes avec des taux de
cortisol c'est-à-dire l'hormone du
stress plus bas que les autres il ya
aussi un professeur en psychologie qui
s'appelle kenneth carter mais qui n'a
pas participé à cette étude là qui
affirme lui de son côté qu'il ya
certaines personnes qui sécrètent plus
de dopamine c'est-à-dire de l'hormone du
plaisir quand elles sont soumises à des
situations extrêmes et des sensations
fortes que les autres un vrai bon est ce
que c'est parce qu'ils aiment ça qui
produisent moins d'hormones de stress et
plus d'hormones du plaisir ou est ce que
c'est parce qu'ils produisent plus
d'hormones du plaisir et moins
d'hormones de stress qu'ils aiment ça
qui de la poule qui de l'oeuf c'est
difficile à dire est ce que c'est la
production d'hormones et de
neurotransmetteurs qui influence la
personnalité ou est ce que c'est la
personnalité qui influence la production
d'hormones retransmetteur en tout cas
clairement le truc à retenir c'est que
on est pas tous et toutes égaux devant
les sensations fortes allez un dernier
petit effet un peu plus niche mais je
vous le donne quand même il ya une étude
de 2016 qui a montré que faire des tours
de grand huit ça permettrait d'expulser
les calculs rénaux les calculs rénaux
c'est des sortes de petits cailloux ou
de petits cristaux qui se forme dans
notre système urinaire et qui se bloque
quelque part ils peuvent se coincer à
différents niveaux là en l'occurrence
pour l'étude c'était au niveau des
calices alors vous allez me demander
mais comment ils ont réussi à déterminer
ça m'a d'abord ils ont eu des
témoignages de patients qui leur ont dit
qu avoir fait un tour de grand huit
salles aurait fait du bien et puis après
ils se sont dit vas-y vient en fait une
expérience donc ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
qu'ils ont fabriqué un rein artificiel
et ils ont calé des calculs de dans des
vrais fournis par des patients et/ou
puis ils ont mis tout ça dans un sac à
dos et ils sont partis faire des tours
de montagnes russes avec oui c'est pas
facile tous les jours d'être chercheur
mais des fois c'est cool comme métier
après c'est pas moi qui vais clash et
ils ont fait vingt tours et entre chaque
tour ils ont analysé les faits que
j'avais eue sur les calculs de tailles
différentes qu'ils avaient placés à
différents endroits du rare ils ont
constaté que si on est à l'avant du
manège ça peut marcher ça peut dépenser
les calculs mais seulement dans un cas
sur six mais que par contre à l'arrière
c'est efficace dans les deux tiers des
cas voilà moi je vous donne ça comme ça
après je sais pas si vous avez déjà eu
des calculs rénaux mais ça pique quand
même faut vraiment avoir la foi pour
aller faire des tours de grand huit pour
l'aider commencer et puis non je suis
pas sûr que la sécu va être ok pour
rembourser les entrées dans les parcs
d'attraction mais au moins vous avez des
infos ou qui en syllabes l'ordre
[Musique]
j'ai crevé
oh
là
on va rentrer parce que tu es trouvèrent
et d voilà maintenant vous savez ce qui
se passe dans votre corps quand vous
êtes dans un roller coaster si vous
aimez pas ça déjà vous n'avez pas vous
justifiez évidemment mais maintenant
éventuellement vous pourrez parler de
taux de cortisol c'est cadeau et si vous
aimez ça faites vous plaisir vous avez
vu ça a été impeccable même si romain
bon
en tout cas merci à un repas par qui
nous a accueillis qui nous a permis de
filmer dans les roller coaster qu'on n'a
pas fait vingt tours d'affilée mais on a
pas mal enchaîné quand même et puis donc
n'oubliez pas ne picoler pas avant vous
bâfrer pas avant je sais vous n'aviez
pas besoin de moi pour savoir ça mais
regardez romain il avait fait les 2 par
exemple c'est faux il ya plein d'autres
situations à sensations fortes pendant
lesquelles il se passe plein d'autres
choses à l'intérieur de notre corps on
aura peut-être l'occasion d'en reparler
bientôt en attendant prenez soin de vous
et prenez soin des autres mettez vous
bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]